all right three qb's have beaten tom
brady after playing him in the super
bowl
name them
don't look down
don't look down what do you mean look
down i don't see him down there beat him
after playing him in the super bowl
right um
beat him after russell wilson's got to
be one of them
right yes right okay
um hmm
it can't it can't be peyton manning
right uh well no they didn't play in the
super bowl eli eli manning did you think
beat him yeah okay i mean damn i guess
i'm going to help you here yes he beat
him in the 2011 regular season before
they beat him in the game why don't we
why don't we just make the rest of the
uh
who do you think is down
i don't know well think about the super
bowls it's down to kurt warner
jake delaume
donovan mcnabb right nick foles and matt
ryan warner kurt warner
yeah
all right and are we sure about that i
feel like i thought i remembered arizona
going to new england in like 2009 maybe
and winning a game there i could be
wrong okay fine they got waxed all right
so 47 to 7. it it was a win it just
wasn't for the cardinals and it wasn't
it snowing or something it was just a
bad bad day for the cardinals oh all
right uh chris go ahead you got the
first pick and the match-up draft for
week five okay i think i'm gonna go to
um i'm gonna go to the browns colts game
i mean i think this is i'm really
excited you know i tend to go with the
the ugly matchups up front and first off
you've heard me wax poetically about
this colts defensive line uh earlier in
the show this colts d line versus brown
zoe line that's what i want to see to me
the browns o line is in that
conversation for one of the best run
blocking o lines in all of football and
i know there's no nick chubb there or
anything like that but damn they still
got kareem hunt and that other kid who
was really good last week too who i'm
blanking on his name yeah ernest johnson
ernest johnson thank you there mr
co-host so i am i'm pumped to see that
because
like i said i look at this colts d line
right now and go oh it feels like the
49ers last year just waves of people
they don't ever have to blitz because
their front four can do it all but this
brownzo line's been a force of nature in
the run game they move everybody so i'll
i'll be excited to see that that go uh
go down on sunday
all right first one for me this is uh an
easy one and i'm surprised you skipped
over it jason garrett versus the entire
cowboy organization because he's back
every time the cowboys play jason
garrett's name is trending on twitter
he's going to be back he's going to be
doing this and it's going to be awesome
so i don't think i need to say anything
more especially since we don't have a
whole lot of time what do you got next
no that's a good one i like that all
right well i'm i'm going to do something
similar to what you just did how about
drew brees versus the chargers you know
the chargers
it's his old team this might be the last
time he ever plays against them this
might be the last time he ever gets to
stick it to the chargers and go ha you
guys were stupid letting me go what were
you thinking but uh i i am excited to
see that the chargers defense got tore
up
you know pretty good last week by brady
and company that's a pretty damn good
defense so i would think they're going
to rebound a little bit but man i liked
what i saw from brees in the saints
breeze and the saints went through the
run game aspect too last week i think
that's their best way their o line and
camaro the best thing they got on
offense play through that would be my
two cents there but i'm excited to watch
that match up
all right we're halfway through the
draft i'm going to take the obvious one
the super bowl 52 reunion nick foles and
tom brady tonight
period i mean it's it's it's going to be
great to see these two guys on the field
again in prime time especially after
what we suffered through last week
between brett rippon and sam darnold
slash joe flacco so uh yeah tonight's
matchup of the two quarterbacks without
question yeah it's awesome i'm i'm
really excited for tonight's football
game uh
it it should be fun the quarterbacks
there's a lot of other cool story lines
to go along with it uh and i like
listening to troy and joe buck i think
it's a great listen i really do um if i
gotta go here
well we don't know if they're playing
but i'm going to pick this i'm going the
titans versus covid all right that's i'm
glad you mentioned it i'm glad you
mentioned it yeah there's another part
there's another positive the news just
came through there's another titans
positive which means oh they lost the
caller
and they're going to lose their game
this weekend i don't mean lose it as in
forfeit
how are you how are you going to play on
sunday and as we said you can't play
monday because the bills play thursday
unless they're going to do something
there to clear out that spot but why
would you want to give up bills chiefs
on thursday night so uh not looking good
titans versus covid kovet what is it now
covet 21 titan zero yeah so all right
should i change my pick should i even
count that now should i go to something
else no that's fine
all right change it we got time all
right i'll change it i'll change it um
i'm gonna go to uh carson wentz versus
the steelers defense watch out i mean
watch out steelers defense is good we
know the philadelphia eagles offense is
offensively challenged and this could be
one of those games that leads to wence
trying to do too much and being crazy
and a bunch of turnovers and losing the
game that way he's gonna have to be
really careful about what he does they
are overmatched by a better steelers
defense i will be uh tuned into that for
sure
i'm going to our game sunday night mike
zimmer versus pete carroll a couple of
defensive guys who are going to be
standing on the sidelines screaming
profanities as the pinball machine racks
up as it's and i'm telling you 4138 is
probably what the score is going to be
or at least in that range we've seen
games like that all year long we've got
two offenses that can move the ball
we've got two defenses that can't stop
the other team especially not the way
they used to and i think zimmer and
carol are gonna be pulling their hair
out chris uh i wouldn't be shocked
you're right they certainly their
defenses aren't gonna you know last to
test the time this year and uh both
offenses and quarterbacks i mean we know
russell had it but kurt kirk and that
offense have found their mojo here
lately to where they're becoming kind of
dangerous we'll see
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports